[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
las quand l'album de slimane on parlera
bien sûr de papa ou maman de alors je
sais pas si vous connaissez c'est con ce
climat et marina c'est jean luc qui
regarde tout ce qui se passe dans
l'émission d'accord il voit des trucs
que nous forcément on voit pas parce que
c'est jean luc lemoine il est plus
intelligent que tout le monde voit les
balance des blancs c'est quoi alors des
questions est ce que voulait une
question il faisait bon allez on y va
bonjour je m'appelle michel
je voulais savoir si vos chroniqueurs
était payer proportionnellement à ce
qu'il disait d'intelligent dans
l'émission et si oui comment font-ils
pour vivre avec si peu c'est une
excellente question michel mais je vous
rassure notre salaire n'est pas indexée
sur la qualité de nos interventions
sinon les fins de mois serait très
difficile façon nous concernant cyril a
compris à qui s'adresser donc ils
s'adaptent depuis le début de l'année on
nous demande nos esprits avec des
pancartes
ça c'est évident de dire trop de bêtises
le problème c'est que personne n'a
compris comment ça marchait avec une
pancarte on avait du mal avec 2 je vous
raconte même pas
j'aime jouer avec deux pancartes c'est
compliqué pour des petits cerveaux comme
nous la semaine dernière nous a donné
trois pour cartes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est tous mauvais mais c'est pas grave
car cyril nous a pas embauché pour ça
non ce qu'il attend de nous cyril c'est
surtout de l'honnêteté alors nos
jugements et aussi dans nos anecdotes 1
si on est honnête syrie peut tous nous
pardonner par exemple jean michel jo il
n'avait pas pu préparer une émission
eh ben c'est pas grave parce qu'il y
avait une bonne excuse il avait un dégât
des eaux
il est très fatigué et pas dormi la nuit
pourquoi vous n'avez fait quoi un dégât
des eaux j'en fais toute l'année ça chez
vous dans votre slip blanc et moi j'ai
pompé tout line beauchamp micro siestes
de 20 minutes parce que leur objet met
un saut j'ai calculé que mon iphone ses
dettes et 20 minutes fallait le vide et
donc je dormais tepa minutes ça sonne et
je revenais est ce qu'il ya dans le
calme et de toutes les 20 minutes
mon iphone sonné pour jacques vider le
soc je n'en ferai pas parce que le
sautron débordés ne votez pas présager
une collection de saut chez moi
[Musique]
ça nous sont dégâts des eaux
là je tournais gazon
la vie est ce qu'il a dit
d'un plombier ou quoi j'ai perdu mon
je vais couper
[Musique]
et le sunnite froid
[Applaudissements]
comment vous avez pu mentir à l'antenne
il a même remercié son concierge encore
pas de consensus qu'il ait pu faire dans
l'autre renault va porter le courrier
c'est tout c'est vraiment fou tu vois
c'est qu'il y en a eu sur génisses un
incroyable talent son petit chapeau
pointu la banque eut alors plus ça
m'étonne de jean-michel parce que
d'habitude c'est plutôt un homme de
confiance toujours très franc et très
mesures excellent regarder
j'ai la réponse moi mais si tu penses
que si tu n'es s'est brutalement et je
crois que le parlement déciderez les
obsèques nationales
honnêtement j'étais que modeste pousse
pas le dire mais
j'en ai vu des faux culs il se fout de
ma gueule
non mais lui c'est un poème 1 mais
regardez le encore une fois la syrie va
faire une blague sur mes origines
asiatiques ce qui est assez rare
jean-michel va être mort de rire
jusqu'à ce qu'il croise mon regard
regardez bien c'est magique et donc tu
manges quoi ce soit par exemple il va
manger quoi excède le soir ces soupes et
c'est bon pour sa santé
bah oui non une souffre iso parce
qu'aujourd'hui peut-on préparer
[Applaudissements]
et
bonjour au revoir c'est là parce que il
est fort quand même
c'est belgique merci oui ben alaoui
merci le fait que vous avez pas assez de
mal à cette émission c'est bon merci
mais j'ai regarder dans le dictionnaire
à planche pourrie il y avait une photo
de jean michel mr n'attendait aucune
solidarité de ce garçon sauf si vous
êtes son ami matthieu delormeau
ouais j'aime bien le mal oui brimades
j'aime bien j'ai mes pièges n'a jamais
pas là deux ans et depuis deux ans je
commence à accrocher je n'aimais pas que
ça marchait ils sont fous quand même ça
marche et on virait
moi non
quelques opus n'est pas possible
oh la la vous n'êtes pas et des syriens
non je ne sais pas comment on fait pour
pour supporter tout ça et surtout pour
continuer à essayer de nous tirer vers
le haut car oui mais malgré cette bande
de bras cassés syrien ne renonce pas
chaque pause publicitaire et vient dire
un mot à ses chroniqueurs pour les
motiver
[Musique]
à droite c'est du cachemire
gentiment trop gourmand gentil il vient
l'eau reste beaucoup
mais les ses limites dans le dos
c'est moche malleray visage c'est ce qu'
il n'était pas content mathieu mais
comme ils pouvaient pas engueulé cyril
pour des raisons de pertes d'emplois et
vu éventuel débat il a engueulé valérie
bénaïm jeudi à venir quel bonheur
[Musique]
c'est quoi vous aimez animera respect
des tunisiens moi je ne sentais rien
arranger les familles
vincent clerc
je parierais sur sa ligne vous êtes très
tolérant cohérent mais j'aime bien aussi
les règles qui est pas crédible et à
tout ce qui vole lui voilà aimez-vous
bon en tout cas vous avez compris si
cyril s'intéresser à votre vie et vient
vous réconforter méfiez vous sinon voilà
ce qui arrive quand vous sortez du
plateau déjà droit
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que j'y arrive
bien en plus oui c'est le genre de
tonnes non merci bonjour assure cyril ne
s'amuse pas qu'à ça pendant la pub non
il a d'autres jeux plus évolué c'est
faire toucher une partie de mon corps
quand dieu tu l'as compris ce que vous
allez faire toucher une partie de mon
corps retrouvés
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme d'hab et cyril aime bien qu'on met
tout sur le zizi je dis que ça porte
bonheur enfin surtout à lui a conseillé
méfiez vous quand même de vos
chroniqueurs par exemple un conseil ne
tournez pas le dos à mathieu s'il avait
c'est juste qu'ils aient pas franc je
pense qu'il va prendre votre place
ouais ça se voit quand on reçoit des
invités il fait comme si c'était son
émission et que c'est lui qui recevait
[Applaudissements]
chéri plaisir
malgré un phénomène à me baby soit drôle
ou un rider drôle amusant bien reçu
quand vous êtes arrivé
badji bon jour très poliment et gentil à
marina aussi vous avez un nom parce
qu'elle était en face mais j'aime
beaucoup ça me donne l'occasion de lui
dire tu conduis dans les quatre tirs
alors on parle et on parlait de mathieu
mathieu qui croient que c'est son
émission et qui accueille jean luc
reichmann me désole matthieu jean luc
reichmann n'était pas venu pour toi mais
bien pour cyril car jean luc hees terry
le sueur comme ça regardez à la pub
quand jean luc raconte aspirer le
scénario de sa série léo mattei série
il est bien passionnés
c'est le frère de 2
[Musique]
alors ils ont la lager
la mosquée à taux fixe et des jeunes
[Applaudissements]
c'est important à ce moment de communion
tout vous résumer on est on s'adore on
lui tombe bien c'est exactement ce qui
va les opposer ya et voilà il ya même
olivier baroux j'ai tout écouter c'est
ça cet extrait gens lui parler de
slimane dans les eaux mattei dire qu'on
en parle souvent de slimane dans tpm p
au moins on les écoute pas parce qu'on
l'a dehors j'ai déjà passé à l'acte est
cher mais comme il aida ce soir son été
dommage de se priver
il arrive quand sous l'écran ça me
chercher
eh ben on arrive bien on commet à 4
[Applaudissements]
ayman excusez le jeu c'est que slimani
prend bien les choses sympas et on vous
a beaucoup défendu pendant ce voyage
ouais je me sens vivre à metz moi je
pense que vous avez peur en grande
partie à quoi vous avez été impliqué
dans marianne en service à ce que vous
avez fait beaucoup de pub et même l est
pas là aujourd'hui mais valérie benaïm
bisous c'est vrai
valérie benaïm elle n'a pas la télé mais
en tout cas c'est ce qui m'a alors tu ne
dois les invités la semaine dernière
nous recevions pascal obispo avec
isabelle verrait bien dans danse avec
les stars
vous pourriez faire danse avec les stars
si un jour vous avez un peu de temps
mais non merci
non parce que je ne sais pas danser
alors heureusement je ne suis pas comme
vous ce jour pourtant vous avez la
morphologie et puis peut pas il est trop
connue la ville n'avait pas vu torse nu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut savoir que c'est marqué dans son
contrat jean-michel dois dire 52 fois
saisi par un missile c'est pas de sa
faute c'est pas possible pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi je dis des conneries
pareilles je m'inquiète mais posez vous
les bonnes questions mais je me lève je
propose donc lui dis toujours si thierry
c'est différent on l'attend pour des
blagues bike qui cherche méticuleusement
sur son portable pendant les pauses
alors conseils de pro si vous voulez
faire passer une mauvaise vanne partez
vous même dans un fou rire tu y habiter
marc blanchet la plage
vous avez raconté à l'antenne ça
malheureusement alheureusement un triste
au moment allez c'est bon de passer à
tous qu'on n'aurait pas voulu ou
entendre cette semaine commence par un
point lexical entre damia canivet zh et
jean michel maire quand vous avez un
doute sur une expression n'hésitez pas
adressez-vous à jean mimi savez la
bateau
jeudi
[ __ ]
j'aime vraiment
pour moi quand unis g14
là où ce n'est pas tout
m
mais j'ai un booking géant d'aimer
distribution je les vois ce week-end
non vous allez où dans son cas c'est
super comme je disais à chaque fois que
je viens et le bateau s'agrandit oui
c'est vrai ce coup tu iras ya que mon
cerveau qui rapetisse
[Musique]
de m
de dollars bords de l'arno d'alarmé
[Applaudissements]
mais il est une répartie mais à chaque
fois ils passent toujours même dit aussi
deux fois la domination des connaissez
peut-être gilles de la tourette non mais
là il a remis jeudi jean michel bayle
excusé mais qu'est ce qu'ils aiment ou
non mais sans déconner non franchement
cela revoir le film est imprimé un papa
et maman
le climat d'un problème ce garçon
décoller lui sa part - il s'est excusé
je suis très content car j'avais tout et
n'avez pas répondu à ces jeux toujours
pas les réponses je t'avais dit j'arrive
bientôt je vais le faire ce soir de quoi
que tu vas faire je dois faire tout et
ce soir c'était y'a buste et est de ce
fait ils arrivent toujours il ne la
chante et de toner au genou tient ce
mois
[Applaudissements]